In this video, you see me dressed in this reflective suit
and our camera system is scanning the wall at a rate of four times every second.
The suit is reflective,
so we can actually capture enough photons
that we can see where I am and what I'm doing,
without the camera actually directly imaging me.
By capturing photons that scatter from the wall to my tracksuit,
back to the wall and back to the camera,
we can capture this indirect video in real time.
And we think that this type of practical non-line-of-sight imaging
could be useful for applications including for self-driving cars,
but also for biomedical imaging,
where we need to see into the tiny structures of the body.
And perhaps we could also put similar camera systems on the robots
that we send to explore other planets.
Now you may have heard about seeing around corners before,
but what I showed you today would have been impossible
just two years ago.
For example, we can now image large, room-sized hidden scenes outdoors
and at real-time rates,
and we've made significant advancements towards making this a practical technology
that you could actually see on a car someday.
But of course, there's still challenges remaining.
For example, can we image hidden scenes at long distances
where we're collecting very, very few photons,
with lasers that are low-power and that are eye-safe.
Or can we create images from photons
that have scattered around many more times
than just a single bounce around the corner?
Can we take our prototype system that's, well, currently large and bulky,
and miniaturize it into something that could be useful
for biomedical imaging
or perhaps a sort of improved home-security system,
or can we take this new imaging modality and use it for other applications?
I think it's an exciting new technology
and there could be other things that we haven't thought of yet
to use it for.
And so, well, a future with self-driving cars
may seem distant to us now --
we're already developing the technologies
that could make cars safer and more intelligent.
And with the rapid pace of scientific discovery and innovation,
you never know what new and exciting capabilities
could be just around the corner.
(Applause)